hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well why would a
person want to begin this strange
activity that we recall by the term
philosophy that's that's a question that
a lot of philosophers themselves don't
have very good answers for in part
because they don't think about it very
much because they've been doing it for
so long now they really want to have
good answers for this though especially
if they're the kinds of people who are
teaching courses to students who are
just beginning the study philosophy you
know why would anyone want to do this
this sort of business what is it all
about that's a good question and there
are a number of different answers out
there
Aristotle's is probably the most famous
but I don't think it's actually you know
quite accurate for many people he says
philosophy begins in the act of
wandering or in autumn on sane and Greek
and I think that's correct for some
people but I think that the patinas
provides us with an understanding of
where people first get this drive to
engage in the intellectual inquiry that
we call philosophy I think that many
people actually do things this way and
he's going to provide us with a great
model of this in book 2 chapter 11 which
is devoted to this very
it's also going to bring in the the
issue of the pro-leg seis the general
principles or a preconception so if
you're unclear about what that means you
should watch the video dealing with
those the core concept video
specifically on that you know he gives
two different answers that are actually
quite compatible and we're going to see
how he brings them all together so the
first answer that again but the very
first line of this section is he says
well you know if we're entering in by
the right door the right gate who knows
right then what we we begin with is a
consciousness on one's own weakness and
impotence and have a some impatience
impotence a lack of resources you might
say regarding important matters or more
literally those things that are
necessary for us the unindicted the
things that are that are absolutely
central for us so one of the philosophy
begin with that sort of effect rather
than wonder I mean you couldn't see that
as a sort of wonder wow things are
really screwed up and I don't know what
I'm gonna do that is where the stoic
philosophy begins he is saying if you
want to enter into philosophy by that
the right door you know by the gate
officially that's where to start
you this is another answer as well
recognition of the conflict Greek word
for that is maje is it's sometimes
translated as incompatibility or as
contradiction in some of these stoic
texts but mine really means something
more like a fighting a striving you know
a mafia is a battle right so conflict
between people why are people getting
into conflict well they see things
differently and they say things
differently and they argue with each
other and then they start shouting and
start saying look you're totally wrong
I'm
right about this and where does this
come from then why do we get into the
sorts of conflicts that we get into this
is a common experience not only in a
Democratic Society where were you know
made of virtue of bringing that into the
political process but and pretty much
every society you're gonna find people
disagreeing about fundamental things how
does it happen
so Epictetus tells us we all begin with
these preconceptions with these
prolapses these general ideas and okay
so far so good
why don't we all find ourselves in
agreement that well there's two really
big reasons one is when people go to
apply them they apply them differently
to know the specific cases and the
situations again this is discussed in
the core concept video on prolapses when
they do that it's because they don't
really understand what they're working
with either these specific matters or
the general principles they have a kind
of a notion of them you know let me
actually give you what he has to say
because it's much better than what I
already have to say about this he says
we come into being without any concept
of a right angle triangle or half
channel musical interval but by a
certain systematic method of instruction
we're taught the meaning of each of
these things for that reason those who
don't know them do not fancy that they
do so if you don't if you don't know
music you don't know geometry and I'm
going to think that you do right now is
you're really I'm a music critic but I
don't know anything about music that's
sort of business
it's different for the the
preconceptions he says on the other hand
who has not come who has come into being
without a concept of what is good and
evil honorable and base appropriate and
inappropriate and Happiness of what is
proper what falls for a lot what we want
to do and what we want
and a whole bunch of other things and
what I'm going to worry at this but
we're these actually come from are they
you know innate principles in a lot the
in a rationalist later on are they part
of our culture and you know is are they
inherent to language itself we don't
really have to worry about that
happinesses is saying look people come
in to come they they ride on the scene
having this moral vocabulary and a
vocabulary about all sorts of other
stuff like the true and the false
and they begin to apply it and most of
the time they don't know what they're
talking about and the guy next to him
doesn't know what he's talking about
either and now in if they're in
agreement or an agreement for a little
while but quite often they're going to
get a disagreement they're not even
quite sure what they're disagreeing over
just the fact that you are actually
disagreeing about something you know
watch when people get into arguments
with each other and they try to clarify
precisely what they're arguing about it
often doesn't go well unless one of them
has been trained in thinking these sorts
of things through and clarifying them so
we all have these preconceptions we
apply them differently to specific
situations and he says you know we come
to the world with a certain amount of
instruction upon this manner already
given us and then he added there to our
own opinion what are the opinions of
other people's we add to this whole myth
mix of this whole mess a whole bunch of
other ideas that are coming to us from
other sources and why would we actually
be so surprised that we can't arrive at
agreement about key things sometimes
even with ourselves we get all mixed up
about this so that's the beginning point
of philosophy for epic is we see people
talking about things that really matter
and they disagree with each other and
now that's the very very beginning how
do we enter into the
we say what I'm doing so how would we
actually become better off with respect
to that how would we overcome this
weakness and impotence with respect to
the things that really matter how would
we get straight about these things well
he tells us there's other things doing
it we engaged an inquiry it's a
tasteless about how these conflicts
arise if we want to understand why
people are disagreeing with each other
we need to do some systematic inquiry
into how do you know what are they
actually disagreeing about what are they
agreeing about how are they
understanding their terms how are they
miss applying things that's the
beginning point we also have to condemn
mere opinion and have a sort of attitude
of lack of trust or it's transitive
scepticism castilla with respect to or
oppositus sorry with respect to mere
opinion mere judgment we need to hold
out the the prospect of there being
something more than mere opinion or else
you know it's just you know whatever
anyone that wants to think but if there
is a genuine good for human being and a
genuine bad if there is a better way to
live in a worse way to live we cannot be
mired in mere opinions we need to try to
get to something like he says here we
need to discover your brain you know the
asus is is discovery or invention or you
know seeking out some sort of standard I
thought what he calls a Connell Canon is
a rule another term that gets used is is
a criterion so we need something that
can get us beyond just mere opinion what
exactly that is we don't have to know at
the beginning point of philosophy right
in there right now we're saying about
how do we actually get started so what
does this mean stoicism is a philosophy
you might say that not only responds to
a crisis that happens
within human lives and human cultures
but makes that its origin point and one
of the central problems orienting the
whole system the goal is of course to
get beyond the beginning but it's also
important to think about where do we
begin so that you know when we see
people struggling we can say well you
know I understand that you're not happy
about whether you heart but at least
here at the beginning point something
that could turn out to be quite good for
you